[Música]
buenos días hoy quiero contarles muchas
cosas así que voy a tratar de correr
porque tengo mucho que compartir con
ustedes y quiero empezar en el año 1980
yo tenía 16 años y yo era un pistero muy
antero en una gasolinera en escazú
y mi hermano franklin nos llamó por
teléfono a la familia y nos dijo lo
logré
soy astronauta de la nasa obviamente nos
impactó completamente la familia y a
todo el país
habíamos habíamos este recibir la
llamada y me pasó me pasaron dos cosas
la primera la emoción genial de tener un
hermano astronauta y esta segunda y
ahora como le quedó bien a mi papá
pucha es levantó la barra bastante alto
bueno en el en el siguiente año mi papá
murió cáncer
me destruyó porque yo realmente quería
mucho mi papá pero mi mamá que está allá
arriba sentada de 91 años
hoy en día en esa época
en esa época que la considero una de las
mujeres más inteligentes que conozco
pero creo una idea como saco este
muchacho de su problema pero lo mandó a
eeuu con franklin y me cambió la vida de
nuevo me mandó a vivir con franklin yo
esté entrega un colegio en high school
allá y me lleva todo el resto de las
tardes a ver a frank en estos
entrenamientos en la nasa y yo lo sabía
pero me convertí en el primer pasante
oficial costarricense en la nasa
no era oficial perdón pero yo quería que
éste fuera oficial
eso me cambió completamente la vida
también decidí ser ingeniero ya no
estaba haciendo llantas estaba haciendo
trabajos pero yo era el chiquillo de los
mandados pero no importa realmente
aprendí muchísimo y eso me definió como
ingeniero yo decidí que quiero ser
ingeniero pero lo que más me definió fue
caramba como comparto esto con la gente
esto es maravilloso que aunque enseñarle
toda la cantidad que pueda hacer para
que la gente sepa este
es una maravilla
que realmente lo motiva a uno y este
desde entonces he hecho eso no he
tratado de motivar a la gente
en 1986 franklin cumplió su sueño y
quiero compartirles este vídeo rápido de
este vuelo al espacio por primera vez
que costa rica llegó a la bandera de
costa rica llegó al espacio
y más
lástima
[Música]
wang chen wei wei
obviamente del estado después del estado
[Aplausos]
el despegue fue de notting y nos
estábamos congelando el trasero
realmente hacía mucho frío y lo que pasó
después unos días después fue que el
transbordador espacial challenger
también despegó en un día muy frío y
explotó y lo supimos después que mi
hermano casi explota también porque
se mandó en una época muy fría en un
momento muy frío en la cual los sellos
de hule los de los cohetes de
combustible se olivos de congelar eso
pues obviamente puso mi mamá ya toda la
familia en crisis mi mamá se enfermó de
una enfermedad que no sabíamos que era
pensábamos que el mal celiaco y pasó
durante muchos años enferma hasta que
franklin decidió dejar de volar al
espacio y seguro
ya sabíamos que eran bueno sin embargo
eso no me quitó las ganas empecé a
promover la ciencia espacial
a todo el mundo que podía y obviamente
embarcada a mis compañeros de la
universidad de ingeniería y física de la
universidad católica y ahí conocí en
esos años conocí a mi novia mi esposa la
crecida muñoz aguilar que aquí está
conmigo
y ella se convirtió en compañera de ver
adelante
y empezamos a hacer un montón de
travesuras para realmente promover esto
así de fue el primer movimiento pero ese
movimiento de aside me permitió entrar a
trabajar ya verdaderamente como
ingeniero como asistente en la misión
galileo y aprendí muchísimo sobre lo que
eran trayectorias de naves espaciales
claro yo era un poquito más que un
office boy pero bueno lo hacía de
maravilla me pusieron a trabajar una
noche de madrugada acá a capturar la
información que veían que venía de la
nave espacial y yo tenía que colocar
unos carretes magnéticos en unas
máquinas para capturar la información y
no se perdiera cuando la nave pasaba
bueno yo iba muy bien desde la mañana
cuatro las cuatro y media mañana y se me
traba un carrete y pasaron como cinco
minutos y yo decía estoy perdiendo
información de las naves espaciales van
a mandar este tipo para costa rica en el
siguiente vuelo
al día siguiente mi jefa pudieron ag fue
una muy buena mujer me dijo no te
preocupes ronald hay un montón de
centros redundancia en la tierra
recibiendo la información así que si se
pierde usted tenemos dónde atacar más
allí aprendí mucho de que los vuelos
espaciales tienen mucha redundancia pero
por dicha me salvó la vida
bueno en 1999 franklin trató de promover
un programa de pasantías y esas
pasantías era el primer programa oficial
que recibía ganadas a estudiantes de
costa rica pero como todo en costa rica
nadie es bueno no voy a decir nadie en
realidad no hubo un movimiento fuerte de
parte del gobierno para moverlo rápido y
se podía perder la oportunidad
estudiarme a franklin y miramar yo me
encargo yo me encargo yo te voy a buscar
gente buena voy a ir a las universidades
a buscar gente buena
y me dejaré a mi mamá mi mamá es muy
buena viendo a la gente la parte del
corazón la parte de la y ella me
acompañó en cada visita que hicimos a
todos los muchachos que investigamos
bueno el primero fue a idear matarrita
en la foto de la de la izquierda de rojo
y luego de ese éxito como hay de armar
otra órbita vinieron los demás
incluyendo lpf jorge o geelbe melania
guerra que va a estar aquí con nosotros
en la tarde andrés mora guido carballo
gonzalo araya josé castro nieto y frank
lavagne este fue el equipo de estrellas
que ahora ahora están brillando en todo
el país y en muchos muchos muchos otros
países y estoy muy orgulloso de ustedes
muchachos
luego en el 2005 franklin decide
acelerar el programa de pasantías porque
ya a sp le queda el laboratorio que
tenía dónde estaban los pasantes se iba
a convertir una empresa privada él se
animó a convertir su laboratorio de un
proyecto ya privado y se le ocurrió que
tenía que poner un 10 por ciento en
costa rica su 90% todavía está en
houston
pero se le ocurrió llamarme y decirme
quieres ayudarme y yo pensé que era como
siempre era una ayudita de no no no me
metió a trabajar con él como director
del laboratorio en costa rica soy me
tocó financiar diseñar construir y
operar el laboratorio y dentro de eso
elegir a este equipo maravilloso que
ustedes ven ahí en esta fotografía ahí
voy a quiero hablar de todos pero no
tengo tiempo así que voy a hablar nada
más de dos rápidamente uno es juan del
valle oa ignacio del valle un hombre
brillante que también lo tenemos una
tarde aquí uy
tengo dos postes en mi grupo
y este y el otro es carlitos que fue un
ingeniero que murió por un rayo pero lo
contratamos en la gasolinera de liberia
y lo hicimos ingeniero era un muchacho
de nicaragua que paso el río con el papá
y la mamá y yo no sé cómo estudió y lo
hicimos ingeniero era el finado de
franklin y un paseo un domingo le cayó
un rayo después se mueren los buenos y
no se mueren los malos pero así es la
vida
este en el 2006 hicimos el primer
disparo de alta energía para propulsión
espacial de plasma esto ayudó para que
el techno se enviara a su gente y le
pudiéramos enseñar al tec a ser también
su laboratorio de plasma que hago
actualmente es muy exitoso arrastro
roque se convertirá en una en un hito
histórico y el equipo de costa rica
estaba demostrando las capacidades
espectaculares que tenemos
para el 2008 yo seguía buscando
alternativas para promover estas cosas
hice muchas otras cosas pero esta es una
de las cuales me gustó muchísimo mi
hermano frank en hacía muchos años ya lo
había olvidado había diseñado un una
cafetera espacial en un infusor para
tener medicinas pero se podía ser café
también
y este se me ocurrió románticamente
buscar estudiantes para que hicieran
verdaderamente el aparato y voy a poner
este vídeo rápido para que lo oigan
la cafetera está listo muestra del
ingenio y el entusiasmo de estos dos
ingenieros del instituto tecnológico de
costa rica ellos dieron forma a la idea
que sean dibujo en una servilleta y
luego patentó este este proyecto del
cafetera espacial pasó por todo el mundo
entero por todo el mundo o sea realmente
fue espectacular la imagen que tuvimos
los ticos gracias a esta cafetera pero
lo que mal mente me hizo gracia es que
daniel ross en este se convirtió en el
director de investigación y desarrollo
de scania en suecia y fue el primer
presidente de la asociación
centroamericana de aeronáutica del
espacio que le voy a comentar ahora más
adelante
aquí tenemos en el 2010 cuando empezó la
historia del satélite se nos ocurrió
lanzar globos globos con experimentos y
esta es una de las primeras fotografías
desde costa rica de costa rica desde el
espacio tomada por tipos que nos fueran
franklin chamán por supuesto y esa fue
una fotografía tomada de un globo de
helio que llegó a 40 kilómetros tenemos
con qué se nos congelado a la cámara a
70 bajo cero pero
y aprendimos muchísimo entonces esa
noche me puse a escribir la idea de
lanzar un nanosatélite y después
a mi esposa a cristina se le ocurrió
presionarme para que volviéramos a
revivir así de que esa sucesión que
habíamos hecho en los años 80 y ahora se
llamaba acá eñ y volvimos a buscar otro
montón de gente de las universidades
y ahí estaba daniel rose fue el primer
presidente pero después apareció carlos
alvarado diseño y todo el equipo que
está ahí por cierto mi esposa que estaba
de blanco y miembro de la primera junta
directiva de acá en y ellos fueron los
que realmente iniciaron el proyecto de
satélite ellos lo ejecutaron y carlos
alvarado diseño realmente fue muy una
persona clave para que el proyecto se
lanzará al espacio esto aquí hicimos
muchas otras cosas más pero bueno no
tengo mucho tiempo así que voy a avanzar
para el 2011
juan del valle que lo vamos a escuchar
en la tarde y jorge will be fueron los
primeros ticos en hacer pruebas de
equipos costarricenses en un avión de d
de caída libre toma diagnosticada en paz
en picada y cada y en 30 segundos se
puede hacer experimentos como si
estuvieran en el espacio aquí uno flota
pero no es así como funciona en el
espacio
para el 2018 lanzamos el satélite fue un
gran éxito rotundo en toda la imagen de
costa rica en el mundo y nos enseñó
muchísimo a trabajar entre el gobierno
la academia y la empresa privada a todo
esto los globos que lanzamos nos
ayudaron florida bebidas banco popular y
gbm así que les agradezco aquí también
están ayudando en este tema
el futuro es muy importante el espacio
es es un mercado importante y lo primero
que pasa con la gente es que le dicen a
uno si uno flota en el espacio porque no
hay gravedad eso es un grave error
hay mucha gravedad de hecho la gravedad
lo que domina el espacio es porque flota
uno a uno en una estación espacial
porque está en caída libre
esto es la mejor forma que tengo para
explicarlo es imaginando una montaña
gigante de 500 kilómetros donde está la
estación espacial más o menos y me subo
ahí suponiendo que puedo respirar y
tiene una piedra la pira va de esta base
de jalada por la gravedad de la tierra
si la tiro más duro pues llega más lejos
pero siempre la sala cantidad la
gravedad más duro pero se retiró a 7
kilómetros por segundo la tierra va a
caer perpetuamente sin editar más
propulsión que el empuje inicial
entonces esos cohetes que ustedes ven al
espacio lo que están haciendo es
tratando de llegar a 7 kilómetros por
segundo pero eso nos permite generar
muchos satélites en el espacio hay más
de medio millón de satélites en órbita
hoy en día y es un basurero
ok y es una de las tareas de nosotros
especialmente los costarricenses gracias
a franklin de que tenemos la posibilidad
de tener un remolcador espacial de
basura el mercado espacial es de más de
mil millones por año la nasa representa
el 6 por ciento pero según merrill lynch
para el 2050 va a crecer a 3 millones de
millones de dólares es como una bola de
oportunidad en cual los ticos nos
podemos montar como un short fiador e
irnos con esa ola tenemos que cambiar la
mentalidad del país para entrar en
industria espacial yo propongo lo
siguiente realmente hacer un esfuerzo
fuerte en educar en ciencia tecnología
ingeniería matemática y medicina
trabajar mucho entre el equipo late
atípica
educar los abogados porque estamos muy
atrasados en la ratificación de este
leyes espaciales internacionales y sobre
todo entender que la tierra está ligada
al espacio para el tema de cambio
climático ya para terminar les puedo
decir que estoy orgulloso de mí de mi
red de mi constelación pero todos
hacemos constelaciones estos muchachos
que nosotros ayudamos a formar están
haciendo sus propias constelaciones y
les dejo un pensamiento que tengo que yo
como empresario
he sido exitoso y es fracasado muchas
veces pero como educador siempre ganado
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]